Twinkle, twinkle little star. Oh. I know who
you are.
At first glance, stars pretty much all look
alike. Twinkly dots, scattered across the sky.
But as I talked about in episode 2, when you
look more closely you see differences.
The most obvious is that some look bright and
some faint. As I said then, sometimes that’s due
to them being at different distances, but it’s also
true that stars emit different amounts of light, too.
If you look through binoculars or take pictures of
them, you’ll see that they’re all different colors, too.
Some appear white, some red, orange, blue, and
for a long time, the reason for this was a mystery.
In the waning years of the 19th century,
astrophotography was becoming an important
scientific tool. Being able to hook a camera
up to a telescope and take long exposures
meant being able to see fainter objects,
revealing previously hidden details.
It also meant that spectroscopy became a force,
say it with me now, for science.
A spectrum is the result when you divide the
incoming light from an object into individual
colors, or wavelengths. This reveals a vast
amount of physical data about the object.
But in the late 1800s, we were only just starting
to figure that out.
Interpreting stellar spectra was a tough problem.
The spectrum we measure from a star is a combination
of two different kinds of spectra. Stars are
hot, dense balls of gas, so they give off
a continuous spectrum; that is, they emit
light at all wavelengths.
However, stars also have atmospheres, thinner
layers of gas above the denser inner layers.
These gases absorb light at specific wavelengths
from the light below depending on the elements
in them. The result is that the continuous
spectrum of a star has gaps in it, darker
bands where different elements absorb different
colors.
At first, stars were classified by the strengths
of their hydrogen lines. The strongest were
called A stars, the next strongest B, then
C, and so on. But in 1901, a new system was
introduced by spectroscopist Annie Jump Cannon,
who dropped or merged a few of the old classifications,
and then rearranged them into one that classified
stars by the strengths and appearances of
many different absorption lines in their spectra.
A few years later, physicist Max Planck solved
a thorny problem in physics, showing how objects
like stars give off light of different colors based
on their temperature. Hotter stars put out
more light at the blue end of the spectrum, while cooler
ones peaked in the red. Around the same time, Bengali
physicist Meghnad Saha solved another tough problem:
how atoms give off light at different temperatures.
Two decades later, the brilliant astronomer
Cecelia Payne-Gaposchkin put all these pieces
together. She showed that the spectra of stars
depended on the temperature and elements in
their atmospheres. This unlocked the secrets
of the stars, allowing astronomers to understand
not just their composition but also many other
physical traits.
For example, at the time, it was thought that stars
had roughly the same composition as the Earth,
but Payne-Gaposchkin showed that stars were
overwhelmingly composed of hydrogen, with
helium as the second most abundant element.
The classification scheme proposed by Cannon
and decoded by Payne-Gaposchkin is still used
today, and arranges stars by their temperature,
assigning each a letter. Because they were
rearranged from an older system the letters
aren’t alphabetical: So the hottest are
O-type stars, slightly cooler are B, followed
by A, F, G, K, and M. It’s a little weird,
but many people use the mnemonic, “Oh Be
A Fine Guy, Kiss Me,” or “Oh Be A Fine
Girl, Kiss Me,” to remember it — which
was dreamed up by Annie Jump Cannon herself!
Each letter grouping is divided into 10 subgroups,
again according to temperature. We’ve also
discovered even cooler stars in the past few decades,
and these are assigned the letters L, T, and Y.
The Sun has a surface temperature of about
5500° Celsius, and is a G2 star. A slightly
hotter star would be a G1, and a slightly cooler
star a G3. Sirius, the brightest star in the night sky,
is much hotter than the Sun, and is classified as an
A0. Betelgeuse, which is red and cool, is an M2.
Stars come in almost every color of the rainbow.
Hot stars are blue, cool stars red. In between
there are orange and even some yellow stars.
But there are no green stars.
Look as much as you want, and you won’t
find any. It’s because of the way our eyes
see color. A star can put out lots of green
light, but if it does it’ll also emit red,
blue, and orange. And our eyes mix those together
to form other colors. A star can actually
emit more green light than any other color,
but we’ll wind up seeing it as white!
How do I know? Because if you look at the
sun’s spectrum, it actually peaks in the green!
Isn’t that weird? The Sun puts out more
green light than any other color, but our
eyes see all the mixed colors together as
white.
Wait, what? White? You may be thinking the
Sun is actually yellow.
Not really. The light from the Sun is white,
but some of the shorter wavelengths like purple
and blue and some green get scattered away
by molecules of nitrogen in our air. Those
appear to be coming from every direction but
the Sun, which is why the sky looks blue.
The Sun doesn’t emit much purple, so the sky doesn’t
look purple, and the green doesn’t scatter as well as
blue. That gives the Sun a yellowish tint to our
eyes, and looking at the Sun is painful anyway,
so it’s hard to accurately gauge what color
it appears. That’s also why sunsets look
orange or red: You’re looking through more
air on the horizon to see the Sun, so all
the bluer light is scattered away.
So we can use spectra to determine a lot about
a star. But if you combine that with knowing
a star’s distance, things get amazing.
You can measure how bright the star appears
to be in your telescope, and by using the distance
you can calculate how much energy it’s actually
giving off — what astronomers call its luminosity.
An intrinsically faint light looks bright
if it’s nearby, but so does a very luminous
light far away. By knowing the distance, you can
correct for that, and figure out how luminous the
objects actually are. This was, no exaggeration,
the key to understanding stars.
A lot of a star’s physical characteristics are related:
Its luminosity depends on its size and temperature.
If two stars are the same size, but one is
hotter, the hotter one will be more luminous.
If two stars are the same temperature, but one
is bigger, the bigger one will be more luminous.
Knowing the temperature and distance means
knowing the stars themselves.
Still, it’s a lot of data. A century ago,
spectra were taken of hundreds of thousands
of stars! How do you even start looking at
all that?
The best way to understand a large group of
objects is to look for trends. Is there a
relationship between color and distance? How
about temperature and size? You compare and
contrast them in as many ways possible and
see what pops up.
I’ll spare you the work. A century ago astronomers
Ejnar Hertzsprung and Henry Norris Russell
made a graph, in which they plotted a star’s
luminosity versus its temperature. When they
did, they got a surprise: a VERY strong trend.
This is called an HR Diagram, after Hertzsprung
and Russell. It’s not an exaggeration to
call it the single most important graph in
all of astronomy!
In this graph, really bright stars are near
the top, fainter ones near the bottom. Hot,
blue stars are on the left, and cool, red
stars on the right.
The groups are pretty obvious!
There’s that thick line running diagonally
down the middle, the clump to the upper right,
and the smaller clump to the lower left.
This took a long time to fully understand,
but now we know this diagram is showing
us how stars live their lives.
Most stars fall into that thick line, and
that’s why astronomers call it the Main
Sequence. The term is a little misleading;
it’s not really a sequence per se, but as
usual in astronomy it’s an old term and
we got stuck with it.
The reason the main sequence is a broad, long
line has to do with how stars make energy.
Like the Sun, stars generate energy by fusing
hydrogen into helium in their cores.
A star that fuses hydrogen faster will be
hotter, because it’s making more energy.
The rate of fusion depends on the pressure
in a star’s core. More massive stars can
squeeze their cores harder, so they fuse
faster and get hotter than low mass stars.
It’s pretty much that simple.
And that explains the main sequence!
Stars spend most of their lives fusing hydrogen
into helium, which is why the main sequence
has most of the stars on it; those are the ones merrily
going about their starry business of making energy.
Massive stars are hotter and more luminous,
so they fall on the upper left of the main
sequence. Stars with lower mass are cooler
and redder, so they fall a little lower to
the right, and so on. The Sun is there, too,
more or less in the middle.
What about the other groups? Well, the stars
on the lower left are hot, blue-white, but
very faint. That means they must be small
and we call them white dwarfs. They’re the
result of a star like the Sun eventually
running out of hydrogen fuel.
We’ll get back to them in a future episode.
The stars on the upper right are luminous
but cool. They must therefore be huge. These
are red giants, also part of the dying process
of stars like the Sun. Above them are red
SUPERgiants, massive stars beginning their
death stage. You can see some stars that are
also that luminous but at the upper left;
those are blue supergiants. They’re more
rare, but they too are the end stage for some
stars, and again we’ll get to them soon
enough in a future episode.
But I’ll just say here that it, um, doesn’t
end well for them.
But, on a brighter note, we literally owe
our existence to them.
And this implies something very nifty about
the HR diagram: Stars can change position
on it. Not only that, but massive stars versus
low mass stars age differently, and go to
different parts of the HR diagram as they
die. In many ways, the diagram allows us to
tell at a glance just what a star is doing
with itself.
This difference between the way low mass stars
like the Sun and higher mass stars age is
actually critical to understanding a lot more
about what we see in the sky… so much so
that they’ll be handled separately in later
episodes. I’m sorry to tease so much about
what’s to come, but this aspect of stars
— finally understanding them physically
— was a MAJOR step in astronomy, leading
to understanding so much more.
And don’t you worry: we’ll get to all
that.
Today you learned that stars can be categorized
using their spectra. Together with their distance,
this provides a wealth of information about
them including their luminosity, size, and
temperature. The HR diagram plots stars’
luminosity versus temperature, and most stars
fall along the main sequence, where they live
most of their lives.
Crash Course Astronomy is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios. Head over to their
YouTube channel and catch even more awesome
videos. This episode was written by me, Phil
Plait. The script was edited by Blake de Pastino,
and our consultant is Dr. Michelle Thaller.
It was directed by Nicholas Jenkins, edited
by Nicole Sweeney, the sound designer is Michael
Aranda, and the graphics team is Thought Café.